hello and welcome to this video that's
good
i'm i'm getting mr oleg sienko again
that was uh a recent recording failure
we had two interesting games and then my
disk space ran out
yeah i now tidied up my hard drive so
i got enough for plenty of blitz games
pre now so we had exactly the same
thing the same opening i don't think he
will play the same
bad setup again i don't believe that
he played with with yeah this is just
garbage
mr graham master but okay
i'm going to refute it again then i mean
he won the game
but um it's still just bad
so i'm going to castle any castle
queenside in the game before
[Music]
i mean you can play all kinds of garbage
in in
in blitz but it's still garbage
so how do we play this queen f3
or awesome e4
okay it's going to go rook h8 and trying
to re-capture this
i can also try to play in the centers
with e4
something like that
or bring the knight over knight e2
yeah it is um
from practical point of view these kind
of sacrifices are often somewhat
playable
they're not good but like let's say in a
in a purely analytical sense but um
they're also not easily refuted
in this limited time control
so going away with this i wonder if i
should
bring the knight over
like knight e2 g3 stuff like that
maybe knight e4 is an option okay didn't
go for that
so g6
and now what what is this
continuation knight f8 e6
g5 something like that maybe
my bishop on c1 is pretty bad
i don't see how i'm improving it easily
okay i cannot
it's got knight g5
yeah okay i'm not happy with this i have
not refuted his opening
his idea i mean and and it remains bad
it's just
clearly an awful way to play but
i have not i have not reviewed it at all
it takes it i take with the rook on f3
yeah i will definitely check this later
in the in the analysis i would like to
know how to
cleanly refute this long castling idea
yeah i still think he should take on f3
it's tough to
see how you can avoid that
i mean if you move the queen it looks
like
both bishops are blunted so
e takes f3 looks kind of normal here
rook takes and then not take then taking
the exchange is probably bad yeah
of course i mean he's a good player he
didn't do that
so okay what now
i could take on f6
wow that looks pretty dangerous
dangerous and then this one
i have no time at all
queen takes e4 for e5
it looks like i should be losing this
position
i really think this must be complete
garbage castling queenside
maybe i'm too dogmatic there possible
and this is indeed not so awful
would be surprising though it would be
really surprising to me
um okay e5
i also can play bishop c1
the queen g3 okay let's play this
does he have a killer killing blow
somewhere
i guess the bishop is just moving
no this one okay um
taking d6 doesn't work so i have to
check here
now queen f2 then queen h3 is happening
okay
in what now is a check no
got queen g3
bishop does not have that many great
squares
this really what's the deal there
and then he's got bishop g3 i have to
still play it
oh i didn't see that one coming
huh yeah i would never resign that
i have three seconds
okay so ah it was a pretty odd game
and i really would like to i mean he
played this twice the game there where
the disk space ran out he also played
like that
and i have a really hard time to believe
that this is possible
so h5 i castled
the engine is not loving this for white
interestingly
i i did not expect like plus two or so
but
that's remarkable
black center is quite quite solid
this is the thing i mean you can often
start flank attacks if your center
is solid it's just like it's like
completely
um it never happens that black
castle's queenside in such a queen's
indian type situation this is why i just
like
by default labeled it as rubbish but
it's probably wrong
it's really wrong
so i castled and in the game before
he castled queenside there which is
evaluated as okay
by the comp so
okay this is this is a strong medicine
but it's
certainly playable in blitz right so it
takes takes
long and it's not really
you cannot refute this seems
0.7 is not much
and comp wants to play queen e1
and then f4
if you have to do this like let's say
you play
as the engine suggests like this
this is not really a refutation
[Music]
because i have made so many strategic
concessions in this position like
my bishop is not great anyway in the
first place and now with
f4 pawn structure is bad and
the engine is on equal which is not so
surprising
i mean black has very very reasonable
compensation here
and queen f3 is leading to a black
advantage
yeah um and it's it it was
confirmed basically in the game
that here i'm in trouble i'm really in
trouble
knight e4 and black is already winning
the idea knight h5 amongst others is
terrible
tm yeah f4 was already
pretty much the only chance takes takes
knight f6 so he played this perfectly
well yeah this is desperation
and black should win this somehow
queen f4 is even more convincing but i
mean what he did is fine right
bishop c1 i missed
you know i came i had no time at all
i'm not even so sure about the final
position
a3 bishop e1 yeah here bishop g3 was
killing right
that that's what i saw
[Music]
and that was killing me
and something
like this i thought
yeah and and he resigned in this
position i wasn't even sure how to win
because like here what am i doing then
king f1 i mean
my king position is just completely
shaky
and it seems to be a perpetual
it was probably shocked
what what he did i mean he blundered
away a win but
most interesting for me is that this um
i mean i
unfairly labeled this as rubbish it
seems to be playable
[Music]
it really seems to be playable what he
did here
yeah i mean i'm sometimes too dogmatic
and this is one of those cases
remarkable i mean this g3 idea is kind
of commonplace nowadays in this line so
i have to check this idea it would be
quite shocking to get this on the board
unprepared
even in a longer time control game it's
kind of odd all of a sudden they push
the h pawn castle queen side
it's um really a remarkable idea
yeah okay an interesting game in any
case thanks for watching